Chloe you talk about
it was so beautiful to see insight into
your strength into everything that you
handle and get a real glimpse into that
so what do you all want to do and I
wanted to turn to you for this Chloe in
terms of the boundaries of this show you
talk about not filming for a while
Tristan and I are complicated trust
takes time is there anything you won't
show or are there no boundaries
um I think for every sister we have
different boundary levels and we all try
to respect that and but I think
and probably moving forward we might all
have and like your boundaries are
allowed to change and mine will probably
change later but I'm also I think a lot
of us are you know what is in the media
is sort of things that we feel we need
to film because it's
in a way unfair to the viewers if they
don't get to see that we've shared so
much about our lives um especially the
older ones we've been doing this for so
long they started as babies so they
weren't
um I guess we didn't expect them to
share as much and they have a right to
set up their boundaries later we it's
been like a free-for-all and Courtney
has been good at setting more boundaries
it doesn't have to be a free-for-all
forever yeah like that totally and so I
think moving forward things might change
with me but who knows I am an open book
and I like to be that way but it can
change at any time so I don't really
know how to answer that okay Kendall any
boundaries for you oh I have tons
like what I well no I think that it's
always been I think like a cool part
about Kylie and I growing up on the show
um and something that maybe we don't
take for granted is you know we got to
see things happen before we got you know
older our older sisters kind of
experienced a life that we got to view
and so just from a really young age I
think both Kylie and I kind of knew what
we wanted to keep off the show or what
we wanted to keep to ourselves and um
yeah I think that it's kind of as simple
as that and you know we learn and again
our boundaries may change one day
depending on the situation but yeah uh
Chris love the new haircut thank you
what's behind the new hair I just you
know wanted to change something a little
fresh you show new hair that's right
that's right you have been the momager
we all know and love uh just shepherding
the family through all of this what do
you want this new chapter to be
um well you know I love that the
episodes are more a little bit
documentary style and I think that you
have a real insight into what the girls
are doing not only you know what you see
in the press or whatever but what's
really happening behind the scenes and I
love that some of the journeys that all
of them are on and there are different
you know passions and for example what
Kim does with um prison reform and
things like that it's just so
interesting to see it from the inside
out and really get a glimpse of what
happens and how they all balance what
they do because before you would see
little Snippets of something and now I
think the episodes are um you know
Fuller of content that shows the whole
story I'm so over this guy two of my
daughters are being considered for the
cover of American vote I probably would
have murdered Kendall myself it was
between the two of us Courtney I gotta I
gotta catch up with you a little bit you
did a practice run on the wedding
congratulations so
when is the real wedding and what will
that look like because we're really
seeing your love story with your soul
mate on the new show you are
um we don't know yet we're just you know
living our best lives and
yeah big small
wedding
we don't know we don't know okay we
don't know well there's a lot going on
with you we will also see this beautiful
fertility Journey what has it been like
to be on the path to baby with Travis
um I think it's
been
I mean it's a beautiful thing that we'd
love to have happen
um but you know the journey is a bit
hard for any women who have been on it
and emotional
this makes me so happy she's never had a
reaction like that for me and it's
happened like a few times highly baby
number two
congratulations but not a wolf why not
wolf
and what is the name wolf was never on
our list okay
um it just was actually something Chloe
suggested
I like the name I don't think anything I
still like this I love it I love it I
like wolf I just was isn't him okay so
it wasn't against anything to do with
the name it just wasn't him and I get
that you know I get that so sometimes
you have to meet the baby I mean I
didn't name any of my kids for you know
10 or 10 days two weeks and I
contemplated changing names like it's
the hardest thing in the world to name a
child
the birth certificate within you know 10
days or something so do we have a name
no okay we have we have some um we have
some baby really strong options but we
haven't officially changed we have some
placeholders so before I officially
change it I just want to be sure we're
seeing that little personality oh
congratulations thank you I can we're
gonna see so much from you a new love
story for you this is a relationship
that I don't think anybody saw coming
from who are you texting Ken does this
name rhyme with feet
and I think the fans really love seeing
you as you said so at peace it was so
nice to see you doing your own thing and
owning so many moments but now your
peace with this guy what do you love
about him what's your favorite thing
about him
um
he's just super genuine yeah and it's
just really fun to just
hang out and do nothing and
watch TV and just do nothing
that's my favorite thing what about all
of the goal is finding someone to do
nothing with it's the best because you
don't do everything with totally but
it's easy to be distracted with people
you can be with anyone distracted but
you can't be with anyone and do nothing
you love running errands just yeah
running errands just I don't know
writing living life I love that in the
episode you said to me that's what's so
exciting is just that side of our lives
like people don't see like I cleaned out
the playroom today like that kind of
stuff gets me
makes me horny it does those normal
things yeah what do you all love about
Pete what are your favorite things about
him
I love that he's kind and really really
thoughtful he's the most thoughtful
person and I love yeah and I love the
chemistry that Kim and him have together
it's really sweet I thought you said the
chemistry I was like okay chemistry
chemistry that can be a new fragrance
[Music]